[Music]
from the brilliant mind that brought you
the martian in the face of overwhelming
odds i'm left with only one option
i'm gonna have to science the [ __ ] out
of this
[Music]
and the smash follow-up hit artemis
[Music]
comes a spectacular new work of fiction
a gripping adventure story every bit the
rival of the martian
awaits you in project hail mary
ryland grace is the sole survivor on a
desperate
last chance mission and if he fails
humanity
and the earth itself will perish on a
spaceship hurtling through space and
time it's up to him
to solve an impossible scientific
mystery
and conquer an extinction-level threat
to our species
a space virus is attacking our sun
and with the nearest human being light
years away
he's got to do it all alone or
does he an irresistible
interstellar adventure as only andy weir
can deliver
project hail mary is a tale of discovery
speculation and survival that rivals the
martian in every way
while taking us to places it never
dreamed of going join me on this
adventure
with ucsd's own andy weir
in this thrilling episode of into the
impossible
with me brian keating
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
today's very special guest it's andy
weir
joining us from a location i assume up
north in california andy
yeah that's right and hi thanks for
having me yeah i'm in saratoga
california which is
kind of uh near san jose it's in the san
francisco bay area
it's a pleasure to welcome you back we
met a couple times when you were back
uh i can't say it's your alma mater
right there must be some word for
for uh when you didn't graduate but uh
you know i think
you uh you've done okay even though you
didn't graduate i do want to talk about
our relationship your relationship to
ucsd
and stuff like that later but i want to
introduce you andy weir
uh author of many many wonderful
works of art and science fiction
including
artemis including the martian egg
and this book project hail mary which
i'll have my producer hold up
on the screen i listened to it i read it
in uh digital advanced copy form
and uh it's a it's a book about a
teacher uh who turns
into an astronaut and then wakes up on a
spaceship
with amnesia and realizes up to him to
save the world from an algae
that's eating the sun now andy i don't
want to give away a spoiler but it's
almost impossible not to so i'm just
gonna say
if you don't want the spoiler just you
know plug your ears for one second
but uh darth vader is luke skywalker's
father i'm sorry
i'm sorry it's time you knew
and leah is the sister of luke i'm so
sorry to give it away but
um it's it's actually you know i love
this book i think it's your best book i
i know you're probably you know tired of
hearing it but uh
but you're right you're tired of hearing
that
but the thing that that really i love
about this book i've listened to
all you know all three of your uh three
of your most famous books the martian
artemis and this book
i think the spoiler grace period is at
least a year so people
you know they haven't listened to the to
the red artemis or the martian too bad
for you guys but
um because we might we might spoil those
books really thoroughly
but i love listening to the book so the
last uh before this one i listened to
this one this is phenomenal
um and actually i think this one you
almost have to listen to it so even if
you buy it please buy the audio copy too
because
yes by both kinds i appreciate that and
the hard copy hardcover copy
and then also just mail me some cash
please
venmo too andy weir
so what was the process like of the
audiobook this time i'll just say that
there's
an incredible uh amount of audio
engineering and i want to talk to you
about that about
um communication because that plays a
huge role in this book
not only that science but also
linguistics plays a huge role in it
i've had on uh stephen wolfram who
played a big role in arrival
and um and the linguistics behind that
um how hard and challenging was it to
record the audiobook this time you
didn't read it but you were
deeply involved in it yeah i was
involved in audible
well they went through a whole bunch of
clever stuff uh figured out
uh it's narrated by the incredibly
talented uh roy
ray porter who is of course
just awesome top-tier audiobook narrator
there
and um yeah they they came up with uh
you know after going back and forth and
trying out a few things they came up
with um
what i think is a pretty good way of
dealing with that challenge
that the story presents in the audio
retelling
and i think they did a great job in how
they approached it
i'm trying not to get too spoilery i
mean i know that we're
i mean you're probably gonna warn your
listeners oh okay here
there be spoilers but there's kind of i
would say two layers of spoiler in this
book there's the normal spoilers that
okay well you're going to learn about
this stuff in the first couple of
chapters anyway
and then there's like an you know epic
spoiler that
happens uh about 120 pages into the book
that you probably don't want to have
around for you
yeah exactly the um the main character
of course in this book is a teacher and
the first place i want to start off
after moving from the uh from the very
multi-talented uh
narration of the audiobook which
narrates not only you know there are
female characters male 2
characters of course your previous book
artemis was narrated by rosario dawson
which was just uh i've had a run of
really good narrators
like that um rc brave was the original
martian narrator
and then um and then it got re-recorded
with will wheaton
that's the narrator and that was just
because the um
the rights to the to the bray recording
expired and so audible needed to make a
new recording
um then uh then of course rosario dawson
narrated artemis and then you know
reporter for this so it's awesome
crown at least for better the main
character
uh who is it astronaut uh grace who
becomes a
um who becomes an unwitting and uh
hero in the story uh as an astronaut as
you'll find out
um and uh and he has amnesia i don't
think that's too much of a spoiler that
comes in very early in the book it's
like right away
that's right i don't want to spoil page
one but uh there you go
i feel like that one's okay i feel like
you know there's this
canard that those who you know who can
do do
and those who can't do teach and here i
am a college professor at your
work did you ever have a teacher you
know and what you did
and and that taught you what you do or
uh do you feel like you're pretty much
self-made and a lot of what you're
becoming successful at
well i mean i guess i'm self-taught on
most of the science stuff just because
it's something that's always been
interesting to me but
um i had i certainly had teachers
especially in high school
that were really influential and kind of
fostering my interest of that
so i'll make a special shout out to mr
fong from livermore high school
his name is nelson fong and mrs cox
and mr nicola who was actually my
history teacher but he just made it
really interesting
yeah i think the depth of uh
scholasticism here
in the book you know i was actually just
teaching my cosmology upper division
cosmology class and i was telling them
you know again i have struggled you know
coming up with the name for what you are
and how you relate to this
unifying university besides epic donor
and i want to thank you
for the weird uh for the weir airport uh
we needed that
yes
but it was uh you know really ripped
from from a lot of modern headlines and
we're talking about things today in my
cosmology class
that you can measure the distance to an
object using many different ways you can
measure it using a ruler you can measure
it using
the angular diameter that it subtends
and you can measure it using the
luminance that it emits if it's emitting
luminance and the inverse square law
and of course all these you know our
tools are used in cosmology
but i think what i love about your books
including the martian which i made
you know required reading for my
students my graduate students when they
go down to chile in the atacama desert
at 17 000 feet
which makes a tiny appearance in this
book by the way
yeah yeah they mentioned observatory
yeah that's right that's right
and i want to invite you by the way i
want to invite you to the simon's
observatory at 17
200 feet in the atacama desert probably
not doing that but
a okay bit middle of nowhere-ish for my
tastes
well it's one of the places nasa does go
to simulate the martian environment
uh but anyway you know yeah the
resourcefulness of the characters
and i know that you're a tinkerer you
reputed to have
still have all of your digits even
though you have a circular saw that you
use to make uh different objects in your
in your home workshop i think there's
some kind of a 3d printer maybe behind
you i don't know
that's a laser cutter but yeah okay so
still that even more impressive you have
all your
eyeballs yeah you have your eyes and
your fingers i have a rule in my lap i
have a sign that says don't look into
the laser with your remaining
uh so was this always natural to you
were you exposed to
to not to lasers but were you exposed to
like curiosity
tinkering spirit building clocks
building stuff were you exposed to that
by
uh by these mentors that you just gave
shout outs to or did it come naturally
to you
uh that came naturally to me i've just
always had an interest in that sort of
you know i i really like mechanical
systems which is funny because i don't
really write about them
but um uh yeah yeah just
just the way things work
has always been really fascinating to me
um
and so uh thinking about the book you
know i heard an interview with my friend
matt kaplan who's a member of the
planetary society
mary radio he's actually coming to
interview me next week here at ucsd
he's a friend um and he was saying you
know that uh
it's what's remarkable about you is that
you uh you have this confidence you have
this thorough
you know research ability which would
make a great graduate student or you
know a research scientist
but you also are not afraid to just say
you know effort i'm just going to make
stuff
up and have neutrinos store you know
energy
how do you balance the like the hard
science where you'll get the exact
because i look these things up andy you
know
i look up the the wavelength and i
actually have these memorized you know
what wavelength lines of the infrared
the co2 absorb at this is pertinent to
the book that's not a spoiler right
there's two right
yeah you talk about it was in the
petrova line you know which which
it doesn't exist but anyway but then
neutrino story how do you balance that
as
a hard science fiction author how do you
balance the realism
with the like just sometimes i'm gonna
say f it and just just make it up
well i mean usually i have to make
something up usually i have to
do something but i wanted to be as
inobtrusive as possible i want it to be
i don't want to you know just give a
ship a warp drive or anything like that
i want to i want to
minimize the violations to physics that
i have to do
in the case of project ailmary it's like
you have to go all the way down to the
quantum level literally before you find
where i was hand waving
and actually you can use neutrinos to
store mass the problem is you can't
store neutrinos um and so that's the
part that i made up
you you could use neutrinos and the
neutrinos really are their own
antiparticle
if you do manage to get two neutrinos to
whack into each other
then they would create two photons in
this infrared band of wavelength
right yeah of course uh you know
neutrinos were proposed they were almost
in the 1930s wolfgang powell we proposed
them
and then for a string of years there
were nobel prizes whenever these new
particles would be awarded and then
famous isadora rabbi said
uh i propose that a nobel prize goes to
the man who does not discover
a new particle this year yeah there's
too many of them um so when we're
looking at yeah so there has to be some
level of plausibility
but is there ever you know something
where thinking in the back of your mind
you know like uh i might be going too
far or do you feel like you've earned
enough credibility
with just your sheer dogged you know
research ability
that it doesn't matter basically
well i mean i i hope i haven't gone too
far but yeah i always try to keep it
pretty minimal in terms of
invasiveness you know to physics so i
never really think i've gone too
far because i kind of if anything
i spend too much time and effort going
further down the rabbit hole than i need
to where i could have just hand waved
much earlier and nobody would have
objected you know
now this book as i said in the very
beginning the only a minimal kind of
intro to it that i can you know
basically there's some form of
life that uh is is afflicting uh
the sun and it's causing massive
destruction now
this not only taps into our global
pandemic that we're experiencing it has
resonance no pun intended with global
warming etcetera
um were all these things you know kind
of going through your mind i mean did
when did you start this project was it
precovid19 on the horizon or
did how was it with regard to the
pandemic and certainly global warming
has been around for a long time right
um right so i come i finished the entire
book before covet 19 struck
so any any correlation between the book
and the pandemic is pure coincidence
um so you know there are some things
that seem to be parallels but
i finished the whole thing before the
pandemic so there's nothing like that
um intentional as for global warming or
climate change um
i never have any sort of meaning or
message or moral in my stories um in
this case it's not climate change it's
not like
man-made climate change it's not co2
emissions it's literally
an alien algae growing on the surface of
the sun
that is now absorbing enough of the
sun's luminance
that earth itself is in danger because
it just is not getting enough energy
from the sun and if anything the there's
even just a
weird thing in the book that um the
global warming is now what they want to
have happen
like because the earth is not getting
enough energy so we want to retain
the energy that we are getting and make
it make it stay a little longer
and so they're deliberately doing things
to increase global warming
right and uh when you look through the
the scientific method plays a huge role
in the book and many of the heroes in
the book are scientists and
and uh and and even you know sort of the
military industrial complex is playing a
role because you have to mobilize you
know kind of planetary resources to do
that
um to what level suspension of disbelief
would come in there
do you feel like such a thing could be
mobilized do you feel like we saw that
in coven 19 at all i mean
you come out of kova 19 thinking that
your the scenario
outline in project hair mary is more
plausible or less plausible after what
we've seen in the last 16 months
i would say more plausible because it
kind of validates my
my beliefs that we can pretty much come
together pretty significantly as a
as a species to like fight a common
enemy and
uh yeah i mean of course you know
it's a little bit different because um
in in project hail mary it's a
global systemic issue it's it's like
everybody dies if we don't solve this
right you can't it there's nothing any
one country can do to protect just its
citizens
right and that's not the case with covid
each country
can make its own rules and implement its
own strategies for trying to slow or
stop the spread or
you know whatever else so it's a little
different um
but i do see an awful lot of cooperation
just in the world in general
um yeah so i'm i'm
i mean obviously we weren't perfect
about it we humanity we weren't perfect
about it and there was some
sloppiness there but uh i don't know i i
feel like we're turning a corner on
covid
um the us is now um making
so much vaccine that we're we're now
starting to send it to other countries
um so in this book i find that there's
either something hilarious
um some juicy science nerd nugget
on every page uh even the the table of
contents you know it brought me to tears
that that library
donation i was weeping andy that was
what
and actually the fantastic people the
isbn is just hilarious
you know that was i played the lottery
that number that
there we go now tell me i mean it's not
a spoiler but you dedicate it to john
paul george and ringo why is that
um i'm just a big beatles fan and
there's a lot of like little beatles
um references in the book so i thought
it was
oh yes yes there were stooges references
as well
so that's delightful but i love
personally whenever i get a shout out
you know it's like
and he's talking to me he knows me he
understands me
he knows that i was an amateur
astronomer and amateur astronomers play
a role in this book
and i i think it's it's remarkable i
talked about this name drop alert name
drop alert
i talked to neil degrasse tyson about a
month ago and he was saying
astronomy is one of the few fields where
amateurs play a significant role where
amateurs are actually doing useful
science they're doing
variable star research they're doing
binary star research
and in your book they're saving the
universe
i find with you amateur writers you
turned you weren't a professional writer
you went from amateur to do you see
commonality between are there other
fields of
amateur science or amateur engineering
uh that seem to convey
you know a certain type of skill set
that's transferable to writing or some
other field
i mean i think a lot of amateur software
engineering
can quickly turn into a profession and a
lot of a lot of like
um really good software comes out of
people just doing it for the hell of it
not you know working for a company or
anything um
what else is there that's really good um
in some of the newer things like 3d
printing and stuff
um professional companies are getting
very good at it but it was the amateurs
with their little home
kits that kind of worked the kinks out
of the system
figure out how those things worked
that's cool
yeah so there's a lot of things where
you know you can be a quote-unquote
amateur and really have an effect on the
field also any
anything related to art or entertainment
i would say
because you can just be you know good at
this stuff you could be like just
a really good artist and you like make a
good sculpture or a painting or
something
and you could start a trend in the art
world and there you're an amateur who
just changed to the field
yeah and and this uh youtube economy
you know mike i've become a creator and
my uh
you know my subscriber really
appreciates it
uh well uh hi hi brian's mom how you
doing
she's my toughest critic you know they
say don't read the comments and i don't
whenever she leaves a comment i do not
read it
um converse of of this you know of the
amateur community is is now prominent
and it's kind of adjacent to your field
in my field in some sense
and that's ufology you know there's tons
of ufologists out there nowadays
and there's a big data dump coming in uh
in just about three weeks
from the time of release of this uh the
pentagon is going to release all this
data
um you must get harassed by you know
tons and tons of
of media requests or or what have you
asked about it
do you think that there's there's like
almost the problem of too much data or
garbage in garbage out
danger or do you think it's good and
healthy that so many amateur ufologists
are out there
well i mean i don't believe that we've
ever been visited by any aliens
so let's be clear but i mean
if people want anything that people do
and take seriously as a science expands
human knowledge
even if it's just to say like yeah i've
confirmed that that thing
wasn't a ufo it was an airplane or that
thing wasn't a ufo it was a reflection
off the camera lens
and so on so there's you know negative
results are just as good as positive
results in terms of um
advancing humankind however i do feel
like ufologists like many
kind of i don't want to be insulting but
pseudosciences
tend to not really follow the scientific
method very well
and they tend to really start with a
conclusion and then really try hard to
work backwards to justify it
and so you'll almost always find some
sort of leap of logic
or some sort of gap in the proof that
just
you know you'd never get away with that
in a scientific paper right
yeah right yeah and that's one of the
contexts that you know
i was hoping we turned to next and and
you actually spoke recently we saw each
other recently you spoke at the seti
institute virtually and i'm one of their
you know minor contributors i haven't
reached the weir level of
the weir airport at the city institute
right
the jill carter helipad yes
but the um but i gave a talk there a
couple of years back and i said
you know if one of my students handed in
the drake equation i would fail her
or him because it's never presented with
error bars you know it's like
you have if you hand in an equation or a
plot and it's it's funny because it's
like here's this equation
and it's got 100 percent uncertainty if
you estimate something
says 100 it could be zero it could be an
infinite or ten thousand alien
and so it shouldn't be so surprising but
one thing i love about this book
you could easily make a version of the
drake equation where uh for each of the
input values you have to specify
error ranges and then you can derive the
error bars
yeah so i do that at my seti institute
talk maybe i'll put a link
here somewhere over there in the video
uh and i do that and i say here's an
example
because one of the solutions to the to
the fermi paradox is that
just as you and i go to the zoo i take
my kids to the zoo that i don't let them
bang on the gorilla cage and you know
and say hey
here we are like in other words the
aliens might not want to disturb us
right so they might be here
but they don't disturb us so we don't
know that they're here because we don't
um
they're not observable because they
cloak themselves for some reason
and um so i did an estimation i said i'm
from san diego as you used to live here
we have the world famous san diego zoo
and wild animal park
and if you remember we had this
sculpture here on campus with this
netting that's
about 17 feet tall and i always say
that's the catch escape giraffe in the
san diego zoo well we always called it
the koala catchers when i was there
i always give it as a quiz for the
visiting string theorists that come here
what is that thing here but actually um
so i gave an example in my seti
institute i said like how many
um how many people are at the san diego
zoo right now and you can go through the
math
and if you don't give an error bar it
could be zero or it could be eight
thousand then
you know and it's actually close to
about eight thousand but uh but yeah so
i think
i think you're right if you can do
something that expands human knowledge
that it reduces the bayesian confidence
interval it tightens it up
and that's a good that's a service and
one thing i love about your
um your your your book and and all your
books is that you
you think kind of like an alien like in
other words
you're kind of coming in uh and one of
those would you fellow human
i know that you are speaking in just for
i am a human like you
i love metabolizing protocol
mitochondrial kept cycle violation
i i love breathing oxygen
we too exchange long protein strands to
communicate
um so uh one
one thing i've thought about and has
been in the astronomical community is
where should we look so one of my
colleagues upstairs professor shelly
wright
she studies optical study and one thing
in the book that you
make quite prominent use of is that
these these algae
you know have a signature and that you
know perhaps other
civilizations might also know about that
signature do you think we've been going
about
seti the wrong way in other words like
should we look for
extraterrestrials using some kind of
universal signature of
that we are aware of i i mean or are we
you know should we
look uh as broadly as possible i mean
well i mean i'm hardly qualified to
comment on that
and much smarter people than me have
already worked all those
questions through at citi but don't they
kind of do that with the hydrogen line
i mean yeah there's a 21 centimeter line
but of course that's a radio line and
it's
you know not as powerful perhaps as an
optical line or you know something like
that
or as the petrova line perhaps yes um
but yeah oh by the way just uh calling
back to earlier in the discussion
uh my answer to the fermi paradox
is um not the cloaking devices or
anything like that
my answer is i believe there is probably
you know just
looking at the drake equation there's
probably intelligent life out there but
i also believe we will never be able to
go faster than light
nor transfer nor transmit ener nor
transmit information
faster than light so i think that
they're you know
if it turns out that the nearest
intelligent life form is a thousand
light years away
like if they're looking at us with a
super advanced telescope right now
they're seeing
like the way things were in the year you
know
10 21 and if we said hi
right now it would take 2 000 years to
get a response you know
so i'm just um i just that my answer to
the fermi paradox is
the inviolability of the speed of light
yeah yeah that is uh certainly not only
a good idea as einstein said but the law
yeah so uh
yeah maybe while we're selling that
topic of aliens i know that's not not
really a focus of the book
you know it's in the large scheme of
things let me just say have you thought
about these you know kind of epic
battles between you know the stephen
hawkings and the
and the elon musks of the world and in
terms of like the great filter
and and you know should we should we
respond if we get a message you know
tomorrow
uh just because they won't know about us
you know it doesn't mean that there
isn't a beam of light coming towards us
right now with some information should
we respond or talking said
you know that would be like ringing the
dinner bell saying i'm ready for
i'm ready for you now for dinner i have
no idea
how to answer that because it's all just
wild speculation
um but i i would think if if
i mean i would want to answer
so uh we talked a little bit about uh
some of the connections
uh in the book between um you know or
rather in your past between your
upbringing etc i think you
read some of your father was a particle
physicist is that right yeah well
i mean in your mind i see my mom was an
engineer um
i say particle physicist generally
because it's easier than explaining the
truth which is
he was a linear accelerator physicist um
so he worked with electrons a lot but i
mean he didn't do
stuff with like you know neutrinos or
mulans or anything like that but uh
but yeah that's what he did and he's not
dead by the way he's just retired that's
why i say past tense on he was
yeah i presume
what's that was that was that slack i
presume up up in the basement
no it wasn't at slack it was an ata
which was um
a program run through uh lawrence
livermore
oh really oh wow oh very interesting
okay
um so i'm going to talk about language
i've had on um as i said stephen wall
from
and also noam chomsky and both of those
gentlemen we talked a lot about alien
communication
and how how one would communicate with
an alien of course in a rival
uh there's an alien species that comes
to earth and
uh and and uh actually communicates
directly through the spaceship with amy
adams character and
um and then the not wonderful novel by
and uh and then of course noam chomsky
has thought a lot about communication
but always there's a gestural aspect to
it and in fact
as you probably know gnome thinks that
there is a
basically a component of language
communication
that is inherently um kind of uh
physio somatic or something like that
that you that you basically need some
way of communicating using your hands or
something
what do you think about communication
how would you communicate with an alien
species
if you just got a beam of morse code
could you communicate with an alien
species
you think or how would you how would you
crack that particular nut or
how do you resolve such things well any
communication you have you would have to
send
something that hopefully they would be
able to um
identify as a key on what what
things mean right and so uh
i don't i i don't know exactly how you
would go about doing that
but it would be difficult for sure and
working out a common language requires
pretty much near instant communication
like
you and the other party like if if you
you know if you don't speak a word of
like you know cantonese
and you're talking to a cantonese
speaker who doesn't speak a word of
english
if you're just like locked in a cell
together you guys will
over the course of probably a day have a
little bit of a shared language
but you you work that stuff out with
communication you point at yourself and
say your name you point at the
you point the floor and say floor and
stuff like that and so
it has to go back and forth and back and
forth if there are two
species communicating across a
thousand-year gulf you're looking at
hundreds of thousands of years before
they even start getting a shared
language going
right that's a so-called chinese room
argument that says
a digital computer in another it's a
version of this
little different than the challenger the
chinese room argument is just
um you can't tell the difference between
if a computer understands something or
is just
regurgitating a pre-ordained list of
responses
um this is like aliens actively
attempting to understand
and collaboratively create a language
but it would still
take a really long time if the
conversation
takes you know has to happen over the
over late years
i want to turn now to the craft of
writing and that uh will take us to
maybe some rapid fire and then we'll uh
move into some other
other domains if you have uh if you have
the time and then we'll wrap up with my
ipad yeah before we do that i just need
to hit the bathroom i'll be right here
yeah let me pause
zoom that okay great okay
so now we're gonna get into the practice
of writing
all right okay so um first of all
i'll do one i'll do one rapid fire
question um
true or false or yes or no is the best
way to
sell your nth book to write your
n plus one book
i don't really understand that question
sorry let's say you you wrote you wrote
the uh project hail mary and you want to
make a really
great success to you i've heard that the
best way to to
you know kind of get attention and and
get get uh
publishers and sell more books is to
write your next book
uh yeah i've never heard that theory
before uh i would disagree with it
okay uh next question semi-rapid fire
is um do you always write a book
now with kind of the idea of a movie
production coming down
the pike no i uh i i and i think that
now my style of writing tends to be kind
of cinematic
cinematic because i see it in my head
like that but i'm not deliberately
trying to make it movie friendly
and um that's because my job is to write
a book if i want to write
and this is what i tell other writers
who are asking for advice if you want to
write a movie write a movie
write a screenplay no problem but if if
if if what you really want in the end
here is a movie then write a movie
um if you're going to write a book write
a book don't sacrifice
good plot ideas or good narrative
techniques because you think it wouldn't
translate well into a film
and what about uh artemis what's the
status of the movie
artemis artemis is um uh
the the screenwriter uh geneva robertson
voret is working on the screenplay
uh she's already made a few revs and
sent them to the directors
we have the directors phil lord and
chris miller attached
and that's kind of the status of where
it is right now
and we have some artists working on um
you know what what the inside of artemis
could look like
and you know some of the storyboarding
that sort of thing
and i understand that uh ryan gosling is
attached in some way to uh project hail
mary's movie adaptation
yeah that's right um for project hail
mary mgm bought the film rights
and ryan gosling is attached to play the
lead ryan
uh ryland grace oh yes that's right
so the league character's name is ryland
grace not to be confused with
ryan gosling who is gonna play him um
also like artemis this is also set to be
direct by phil lord and chris miller
uh we have drew goddard working on the
screenplay he's though
he's the guy who uh did the screenplay
adaptation of the martian so
obviously his skills speak for
themselves and uh mgm is really
seems pretty excited about it so i feel
like it's got a
good chance of being greenlighted we'll
see you never really know with hollywood
and is that pretty hands-off like would
you be in would you go down would you be
involved in it or would you just be work
uh well i mean i am involved in uh
project hail mary i'm actually a
producer on the film
so yeah but uh
the the reason i'm a producer is um so
that i could have some
some of the front-end gross um
just money-wise and so uh i'm
my main objective is to stay out of the
way of the real producers
but the end result is i am involved in a
lot of these decisions
i'll offer my opinions but i try not to
make ways or get in anybody's way
right right um next up
i have uh let's see
um okay do you write every day do you
have like a writing target
thousand words a day do you have any
kind of writing schedule daily habits
rituals
when i when i'm working on a first draft
i try to make a thousand words per week
day
or more accurately i try to make 5 000
words a week with minimum levels so
the system i came up with is like by the
end of monday i i need to have a
thousand words written by the end of
tuesday i need to have 2000 words
written for the week
wednesday 3 000 and so on all the way up
to 5000 for friday
that system i kind of worked out over
time
that way if i'm if i'm if it's like a
monday and i'm plugging along and i blow
through a thousand words
i'm not encouraged to stop right
i'll just keep going and say now i'm
working off tuesday's debt you know
so um that's that's the system i came up
with
although right this moment i'm just kind
of free form messing around working on
the research for my next book so
i'm not writing yet do you have any
other rituals
meditation exercise
no not quite so much uh no no big game
hunting
no rituals just just plugging along
just doing the work huh i'm a much more
boring guy than people suspect
yeah no that's that's uh that's well it
comes across but it's a good thing i
think it's
okay better than you're like uh living
like hemingway and then uh you know
meeting an untimely end uh okay best
part and worst part about being a writer
professional writer
well the best part of course is that
you're your own boss you get to
yeah and also it's one of the few
creative
jobs where you're basically a dictator
i mean aside from a site from your
editor you know
giving you notes and stuff you are the
sole arbiter of what does and doesn't go
into the story
if you're in film well there's a whole
bunch of people who get input there's
the
the you know the the screenwriter the
director the performers often have
things to say the studio and so on
but when you're a writer of a novel it's
just you
so that's kind of cool the downside is
is you have to motivate yourself
there's no one breathing down your neck
i mean sometimes if you have a contract
then your editor might give you a call
but
um for the most part the the bad part of
being self-directed is you have to also
be self-motivated and that can be
difficult
and i also miss having a team of people
that i work with because i came from
software originally
and i miss like going to work i miss
well of course everybody does right now
but
even before the pandemic i i missed
going to work i missed being part of a
team i missed
you know that environment that
camaraderie that comes with it i
i really enjoyed my job as a software
engineer and the last
engineering job i had before i left i
liked it i really enjoyed it and i
i hung on there much longer than i
needed to just because
i liked the work i liked my co-workers
so i missed that i think one of the most
surprising things in the book is how
prominent and important
the role of microsoft excel is in this
book
it's true and uh yeah
go ahead uh yeah uh ryland ends up using
excel a lot to keep track of a bunch of
data
yeah it made me think of uh one of the
dirtiest secrets in the publishing
business i i assume for you too
uh is that uh much of publishing is
accomplished by emailing microsoft word
documents across the country with track
changes
is that true small absolutely
no doubt about it there's got to be a
better way uh come on andy we got to
figure out a better way
i'm sure i'm not sure there's a better
way though because
like it's a really efficient way attract
changes is track changes in the comments
and the notes and stuff like that that's
a really good way of
of doing uh editing passes with multiple
people involved um so i've got no
complaints with it
yeah it's just yeah maybe they could be
there could be yeah there could be maybe
a more secure way to pass the document
around
yeah and then real-time updating or
collaboration or something like that
i don't know i mean you could do that
with google docs if you really wanted
but yeah i just don't like that i don't
need to
see each individual letter show up
you know at the moment my editor is
writing a message on the thing it's okay
and and also um it's best if i don't see
anything until he's done
and reread them and sent it along right
there's a lot of mid-air collisions you
could have where he writes a comment and
then decides no i don't want to say that
but i've already seen the comment now
i'm working on it you know
i guess in the non-fiction world you
know where you're like writing a chapter
that's standalone
you want to like compile you know and
just separately write chapters and then
compile the whole thing i don't want to
email you know 80 000 words every time i
change a word in a chapter but
uh that's a small thing what about you
narrating an audio book any any inkling
to do that ever
no i don't think so um i'm uh you know
i i don't consider myself a particularly
good voice actor
and also um the the narrators that
we've been getting from my books are
just fantastic i mean
so why would i ever want to displace any
of them i mean like these are top tier
narrators
so i i hope that trend continues yeah
okay uh next um
best and worst writing advice you've
ever
uh received well the best writing advice
uh well i mean at the risk of sounding
douchey i think the best writing advice
is piece that i came up with
which is um don't tell your friends and
family your story idea
well you could tell them the basic idea
but don't tell them the details of the
story
because it satisfies your need for an
audience and saps your will to actually
write it
so that's that's a good piece of advice
um
let's see bad writing advice
um yeah i don't know i'm having a hard
time thinking
of any bad writing advice i i do know
some people who are like
oh i like to write the fun scenes first
and then
back fill in with the intermediate with
the connective tissue kind of scenes
and i think that's a terrible idea
because you'll write all the fun scenes
and then you have nothing but miserable
work ahead of you
and so you won't do it so you'll never
finish
that's what i always tell my students
whenever they like solve something i go
congratulations now you've earned your
ticket to an even harder problem
exactly um do you feel
like you've achieved what uh neil
degrasse tyson and i
we discussed as like niche fame like he
in covet time says
he can't even go on the subway with a
mask on you know like yeah
like he's too famous you you are you
just famous enough
do you feel like you get recognized your
trademark chapeau
glasses and no i mean i don't get
recognized that much that's the cool
thing about being a writer you're famous
when you want to be um
yeah if i'm at a convention or something
like that i'll get spotted all the time
you know
but if i'm just out in the wild i mean
maybe once a month someone will
recognize me
that's about it and that that's you know
pre-coveted
back when you know you go to the grocery
store or restaurant or whatever
it'll be rare but it'll happen okay do
you like
or hate getting feedback on bugs like
uh do you give a bug bounty when someone
one of your readers say one of my
undergraduates finds an
error in your book um i like it i i like
that my readers are engaged enough to be
looking at it at that level and uh you
know
i bring it upon myself because i i tell
everyone hey i write scientifically
accurate science fiction
and they're like really let's see about
that and so i certainly can't whine
if they do hit me with some truth you
know
all right well i got some truth for you
andy you ready yeah yeah
i know a few i know a few that i messed
up all right well you messed up the
uh countries that use the imperial
system
united states there's not two there's
the united states
there's liberia oh i didn't know liberia
there's uh
you do you do have i think you say
liberia but it's liberia
and then there's myanmar and burma okay
now i'm john mara and burma are the same
thing
there's one more typo that so my
undergraduate ben found that one
uh but i found one that the earth you
talk about magnetic fields in a planet
when you're talking about a certain
planet that shall not be named
right you talk about um planets need a
liquid
uh uh core a molten core i like the
earth but the earth has a solid core
oh we have the melting mantle yes so
there's the other
ones in the whole book well there's more
um
there's a an alert reader on uh
twitter sent me that at one point he
powers and a little white
led with a like a watch battery yeah but
a watch battery doesn't have enough
voltage to power a white led
or so i was told i have to think about
that the red ones
can be lower but the white ones i guess
need
more high voltage uh yeah or or
something like that i mean obviously i
don't know what i'm talking about here
i'm just going off of um yeah what the
guy told me hang on a second i can i can
find
only there was a kind of a world wide
web we could look that up yeah but who's
gonna
do that no well i was actually looking
for
um 3.6 volts um uh yellow is 2.1 volts
um watch battery i'm sure my emergency
is going to love it he says hi i just
finished hail mary and promised a nice
five-star review
40 years of science teaching and only
one quibble you can't light a white led
with one watch battery
uh it needs 3.6 volts minimum so three
three cells in series would do it
so i guess a watch battery has like a
little bit over a volt like one and a
half
volts yeah it has
yeah it has watch battery it depends on
the watch itself
of course the apple i can't have the
apple watch or a cr
uh e32 as three volts yeah anyway
tell them to stuff it tell us what are
you talking about this is what i'm
dropping
i'm joking i know i know you're joking
but i'm like these are
exactly i i i open myself up
by being meticulously accurate
everywhere where else and
claiming that i'm accurate that's right
i bring this kind of
uh this scrutiny you are thinking in
public and you're doing what a good
scholar should do which is to be
intellectually honest which is why i
knew i could bring up
those two faux pas those fall pause okay
we're coming to the end here andy i
promise
uh and the last thing okay so we talked
about teaching
we talked about um before i get into
okay so would you ever want to be a
professor
would you ever want to teach writing no
uh no i wouldn't want to teach writing
no um but i might want to teach a
science field
i i really like i i don't know there's
something i i really enjoy
explaining science to other people and
so i
i but i'm not i'm not deeply despite
what it appears
to be when you're reading my books i'm
not i'm not really
qualified to be like a you know
upper division professor but i could
probably teach like lower division
physics
like like 1a 2a that sort of stuff i
could i could teach those
and those are the names of our physics
classes here at ucsd which brings me to
my last you know major
set of questions so i want to ask you
about that um
i don't think we've ever really
communicated about this if it's not a
too painful i had a reader i had a
reader i mean i had a viewer a
subscriber
in addition to my mom and he went to
ucsd and i'm not using his name
i didn't say if i could or couldn't so
i'm just not going to but he said he
didn't have a great experience
and he said he wanted to come on my show
anonymously to to talk about why i
didn't have a good experience he was a
physics major
and and he said you know why don't you
ever have on somebody like me and i said
well you know what i'm going to have on
someone who dropped out of ucsd
i'm going to ask him the following
question and i'm going to ask you andy
what
what could we have done differently you
know is there something that we could
have done we have vast resources i don't
care
we're a public universe we're building
40-story dormitory with ocean view and
everything
in there we have resources just because
we're a public university i'm a public
servant
i believe it's my responsibility to
taxpayers to to teach and educate
california's students um what could we
have done better for
for a student like you too i i think
it's not me it's you i think um
basically i was at a point in my life
where i just wasn't really to put it
really willing to put out the effort um
i had
like a lot of semi-smart people i
breezed through high school
without really having to do any work at
all like it was so easy for me
and then you get to college and it's
like it's real work
and i never learned good study habits i
never learned
any of that stuff and so it was just
really hard for me
now ostensibly the reason i left was
because i ran out of money
and that's true i did i ran out of money
i couldn't afford to go there anymore
um but i mean if i
if i had been working diligently toward
a goal and i'd been making
you know getting good grades and was
feeling like i was making progress then
i probably would have found a way to
make it happen
student loans or something else so i
guess for me i just didn't feel
like super directed i didn't feel like
um i just wasn't in a mindset to really
put the effort into college
also remember i was in computer science
and at the time
the tech boom was just beginning and so
there was also an economic thing i was
like
i could either go deeply into debt to
continue
this and get a college degree or i can
immediately right now
start making a decent salary because no
one in the tech industry seems to care
if you have a degree
um also so i i don't think there's
anything ucsd could have done
differently
although one thing you know at the time
i was there i'm sure things are
different it's been a million years but
at the time i was there
um the cs department was like woefully
behind
the times in terms of what it taught
like
no we've moved around up to cobalt or
now okay that's right
glad to hear it yeah no whatever and
excel we teach excel exclusively
excellent
no but when i was there um in a world
that was
all basically uh c plus and java
um at ucsd they didn't have any classes
for c
plus no classes for java they had one
class for c
straight c and it was an elective and
um mainly they taught pascal very proud
of having invented pascal so they kept
teaching it
way too long um you know and so
those are those are some factors also i
i also think that
um in general in this country people are
a little too obsessed with college
degrees
or acquiring them they're not as needed
for employment as people seem to think
and it's so expensive to get one it's
just like
don't go horribly into debt
that's going to take you half your life
to pay off just to get an
art history degree so you can become the
regional manager of sales at some
company
you can go straight into the sales job
you know like
and there are tons and tons of
professions out there
that where you don't go to college you
go to a trade school
and these are not like these are
critical
parts of society i mean we need
mechanics we need locksmiths we need
plumbers we need all these things
and you don't go to college for those so
you don't i don't know there's
there's some sort of notion that
college makes you a properly educated
and somehow
better than those who don't have college
degrees
and i don't i don't like that and i
guess finally i would say this is not
nothing directed at ucsd this is all
colleges
for me higher education should be i am
investing in my future i'm paying an
institution money
so that they will teach me the skills i
need to go out and be able to demand a
higher salary in the job market
like i'm going to learn i'm going to
learn how to do something most people
don't know how to do
so that i can get paid a good salary for
doing it right
but colleges are still stuck in frankly
this
you know 18th century gentleman mode of
not really being focused on you know
increasing your skills as a potential
worker
but on giving you this comprehensive
education
and i'm like i can understand that
happening in high school where you get
like a big broad education
because they're trying to bring you up
to speed with what we consider a minimum
amount of knowledge for an adult in our
country
but for college i'm paying you to teach
me stuff so i don't want you
if i'm paying you to teach me how to
program computers i don't want you to
say i don't get a degree until i write a
report about beowulf
you know so i i just uh and i know a lot
of people disagree with me on this
but i don't buy into the comprehensive
education thing
i honestly think all colleges should
work functionally like trade schools
if i go to a college leading computer
programming that's all i want to hear
about when i'm there
nothing else
yeah very good yeah i agree and i think
colleges are maybe
uh shooting themselves in the foot
because you know eventually it's going
to dawn on people that just as you know
harvard doesn't teach you know so
there's not some special brand of
physics that harvard's learned that
you know i haven't learned yet you know
like some there's a fifth maxwell's
equation that hasn't made its way to the
west coast yet
no we all know the same things we all
teach from the same textbooks
and uh and that means it's very
vulnerable to disruption via
you know technology like into artificial
intelligence like who would you rather
learn
uh electromagnetism from brian keating
or from uh james clark maxwell
and i think as we get more and more like
that the colleges have to differentiate
themselves by
the perks and that's why we have ocean
view dorms here and we have the andy
weir natatorium you know
we have uh you know that's the only way
we can differentiate ourselves and
you're absolutely right it should have
elements of of this but
you know it's uh it's it's it's a tough
nut to crack but i think if colleges
don't rise up to this
you know kind of serving a customer
rather than just like
what this ideal system is as you call it
the 18th century british gentleman
which which is kind of the modality it's
been stuck in you know maybe even longer
i mean i looked up the first college
ever was like in bologna and eight
and one thousand eighty and then
basically some old dude standing up on a
stage scratching a piece of
rock on another piece of rock and you
know i have a white board now and a
marker and that's it that's the only
thing
oxford was founded in the in the
thousands or 1100s
that's right oxford university is older
than the aztec empire
yeah that's right and almost nothing has
changed there's just you know different
different
disciplines and well i mean they don't
do sacrifices anymore oh you mean oxford
okay yeah they still do sacrifice they
still do
you go to the pitch you'll get uh sir
roger penrose frequent guest on the show
all right last question just before we
go to the final thrilling three
if you could adapt any science fiction
novel into a movie
other than your own andrew uh what would
it be
and why this is from my friend jacob
kuhn i think i would go for
probably caves of steel by isaac asimov
um first off it's a really good book
it's in the robots
uh genre you know the three laws of
robotics and stuff like that
and it's the first book in a series so
it'd be cool if they made that movie and
then it was successful and then they
made more
awesome okay andy we are now in the
final section the so-called thrilling
three
where i asked the thrilling three
patented questions which i'm patented
just a minute ago
please do subscribe and like and comment
on this and go to my website
briankating.com you'll get notes and
resources and get a chance to maybe even
win
and copy of project hail mary this
wonderful new book
by today's guest ucsd attendee
uh weir that's a good one right
ucsc attendee ucsd megadonor okay
i've donated a cent to you guys i don't
know why i know
i think i think our relations is going
to come and get me okay
the first one has to do with your near
future when you reach the so-called
biblical age of 120 years old
what ethical wisdom do you want to put
not your material wealth not your
earthly possessions but what material
wisdom
or values do you want to articulate to
give to future generations
uh as an inheritance for the future
um i don't know it's like
i guess i i would mostly just
pass along like not everyone in the
society can relax and kick back
like you you have to pull your own
weight i guess you have to do your share
of society's work i guess you you you
have to
i guess it's an old thing but um
give more than you get i guess
fun fact in the in the bible there's a
commandment to take a day off every week
but people forget that the other command
part of that commandment is you have to
work six days a week
it says you must work six days a week
which some of my kids don't recognize
i'm just kidding
number two involves an up-and-coming
science fiction writer by the name of
arthur c
clark just getting started is he
okay you might have somewhat of a career
you might hear of them someday anyway um
you might remember uh 2001 a space
odyssey there are these monoliths these
menacing
vehicles or capsules or whatever that
are
built by some unseen extraterrestrial
species which are eventually discovered
by our solar system by human beings
and the response of the characters to
these messages or warnings kind of
encourages humankind
to progress first they're seen on the
savannah in africa then on the moon and
floating around in other words
i want to ask you andy if you had an
opportunity to make your monolith
and have it last as a billion year time
capsule not just
what would you put on it or in it to
kind of
maybe triumphally declare what humankind
had learned
in our existence probably a bunch of
dick jokes
not fart jokes you know that was the
oldest joke ever okay there we go there
we go yeah
no i don't know i mean to people a
billion years from now they're not going
to be able to learn anything from me so
i think a value of a monolith
from our era would be in learning about
our own culture and our own history
and what we were doing back in this
ancient time so i guess i try to impart
information about
history or history up to the present
and that would be done uh exclusively in
an excel document right
uh lastly now we're going backwards in
time and as you know this arthur c
clarke personality had many laws one of
which
was for every expert there's an equal
and opposite expert
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic and that's
how we open the show
every week on the show i'm going to open
with his actual voice
it's pretty cool we got him to read it
from beyond the grave now we found it
somewhere
here at the arthur c clarke center for
human imagination at uc san diego but
his third law
states the only way of discovering the
limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible and that's the
origin of the name of my podcast
i want to ask you andy what mysterious
aspect of life
might have perplexed you as a 20 year
old a 30 year old but now makes sense
because
you had the courage to go into the
impossible in other words
what life advice would you give to your
20 year old self
well i was a real screw up at 20 so i
mean
i've got i would probably have reams and
reams and reams of things to say
to my 20 year old self but i guess
the number one thing i would tell my 20
year old self is
you have a problem with anxiety and
depression
you need to get help for it your life is
going to suck until you get that help
and then your life's gonna get a lot
better
so go do that now so i guess just
identifying that i had that problem
was i wish i'd been able to
identify and act on it earlier
how did you do that actually andy how
did you how did you achieve that
um betterment of yourself well um
you know my main problem is anxiety i
mean i had real problems with depression
when i was in my 20s but as i got older
the depression
just kind of became anxiety instead
and you know throughout the 90s and
stuff if you if you wanted to get help
for
anxiety it was generally like you'd be
told oh
here do some breathing exercises or
something like that which is kind of
like bringing a bucket of water to a
forest fire
it's just you know useless um
or or just suck it up you baby you know
kind of
advice but then um it's actually when
the martian came out and it got popular
and i was horribly afraid to fly
i i'm still am but whatever um
i had a huge fear of flying and i was
saying no to you know people would
invite me to one place or another and i
said no no no
but then nasa invited me to johnson
space center for a week of vip tours
and i'm like i have got to do this right
i cannot
i can't i i need i want to do this
and so i i said like all right maybe i
can get some pills that'll knock me out
you know to be on a plane so i started
talking to a doctor
a psychiatrist about that and um
she said okay we can work on that but
also you know
let's work on the you know persistent
generalized anxiety that you definitely
have you know
and so she she she ultimately gave me
pills that
let me fly and she's like that's great
but i also want to
deal with the long-term anxiety so i
guess what happened was i went to a
doctor for one thing and she said i'll
take care of that thing
but also you have this other problem and
let's work on that
and so um she did and she gives me uh
now i have like long-term anti-anxiety
meds
um that i take and they help a lot
they've really improved the quality of
my life it's not like this magic thing
it's just things are now manageable you
know
and um i do therapy every week which is
if you broke your leg you wouldn't be
surprised that you have to do physical
therapy as part of your recovery that's
exactly right i just started doing
therapy
as as part of the podcast i have a
sponsor now
who does therapy and i was like how much
i don't need to do therapy
but i was like i don't sponsor something
unless i actually try it
so that's why i'm doing these roman blue
pills i'm taking these bloopers
i'm just kidding i'm not doing those but
i can say i'm going to do this online
therapy and i have resistance to it
because i can solve my own problem
but i've been doing online therapy
through through this i'm not going to
mention it because this isn't an ad
but um but i but i said to myself you
know
i go to a trainer on occasions i mean
can't tell from the
massive physical specimen you see before
but you know we have trainers for we
have coaches we have you know all sorts
of things
why not do that as you say if you hurt
your leg you'd go to a freaking doctor
and this is just like a coach so i i i
think you're incredibly
you know courageous but but i think it's
in your self-interest to do it right
it's my one little i don't know you know
for some reason i guess you get a soap
box handed to you as soon as you're
famous
but this is my quote-unquote cause is to
i guess to try to design
de-stigmatize anxiety and depression and
just
just if you tell if you tell somebody oh
man i
broke my leg people are like oh that
sucks man sorry to hear that
but if you tell people you're like
suffering from chronic depression or
anxiety there's a little bit of a stigma
still to it
and so i you know if i can do anything
to destigmatize it
then that's good and you know
by just kind of saying like hey
everybody i've got this problem
one of the most comforting things for me
ever was uh read um
reading um carrie fisher's autobiography
um was it something
drinks drinking wishful drinking is what
it's called
and she's hilarious or her the book is
funny as hell
but also it's just it made me feel good
to see
you know carrie fisher's problems with
like bipolar disorder and it showed me
oh hey you can be
kind of a little bit broken on the
inside and still be incredibly
successful and and beloved by everyone
you know that's carrie fisher
right yeah and a sad analog to that is i
came within a
i came within two weeks of meeting her
and i wanted to tell her that
i wanted to tell her how much her book
affected me
and but she died um um about two weeks
before a convention we were both going
to be at
ah that's brutal yeah ah that's that's
awful yeah i
once got to almost got to meet herman
woke who lives not far from here and i
always wanted to be i'll meet
him he died like a couple weeks before i
got to meet him
but it's interesting that you mentioned
all this andy because may our
right now is mental health awareness
month
this is a huge service that you do and
you know i've always
loved it's hard to believe that you know
you could have even more
appreciation and respect than i already
did but andy i want to thank you so much
for your uh for sharing your time and
being a friend of the arthur c clarke
center here
in uc san diego you're always welcome
here your money's always welcome no i'm
just kidding
of course i'm just kidding andy um your
bitcoin that your blockchain i thought
that's what we're going to say is on
your monolith
[Music]
um anyway andy thank you so much for
coming on the show i wish you all the
best of success and abundance
and and and serenity too take time for
yourself and i hope we can get together
again i always love being in your
presence
someday after the apocalypse best of
luck eddie take care
all right thank you
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
you